this here is a tiny L will call him
Haruki outside
he's shiny because he's covered in gold
foil he lives in Japan more specifically
here in the town of Kanazawa and he's
not the only shiny thing you'll find
there about 99% of the gold foil in
Japan comes from Kenneth Dawa meet Luigi
a person is my Lamas - Murdoch a mosque
near to our King I could not say go stay
he must there - King me
Ginsburg in or video limited tag gold
who so could the bus terminals also each
other external that is really committed
a very thin paper the hakuna go today
you know Antony Moscow
so no kinkaku tsuki no bestia hmm the
news media King pakal's castamere toe at
sadhana on a meeting where I'm at a gold
foil used to be made in other parts of
Japan but over the years almost all the
production has been moved to Kanazawa
where workshops in vendors line the
streets
Kanazawa image it's all happening so not
extinct not sleep until you are written
off by taking pockets to do Japanese on
tonight by our city on German right
dyskinesia the artisans that make the
foil sell it to local craftsmen use it
on bowls
chopsticks lucky cats Allison look
there's a rookie tilted about the cornea
Hindi anymore
consummate so could you hang that study
talk our foods like ice cream but for
Kenichi gold foil is more than the
novelty you want a normal nose of a
needle
Queeny he takes pride in what he does
not only for his own satisfaction but
because it ties him to his national
identity for say see no meetin a model
code re the you know I are putting you
home no soul along to the car
Manon zucchini and that makes a rookie
Sparkle with joy ah Haruki
[Music]